hey I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the
trailer for a 22 Jump Street I really
liked the first one a lot
that sucked Chang's hands dick all right
here we go
well I hope never to see you again yes
so doc we're back yeah yeah nobody gave
a [ __ ] about the Jump Street reboot but
you got lucky so now this department has
invested a lot of money to make sure
Jump Street keeps going problem is the
Koreans bought the church back so we're
moving you across the road to 22 Jump
Street is every college look like babies
some of us are trying to study so take
it down to a level of [ __ ] on the level
you're looking for you look really old
to oldest [ __ ] to be here partners for
life
yeah it's just drinking games and
bonding why is that so painful for you
yeah you cannot hug me right now we Jump
Street and we about to jump in your ass
mm-hmm right in the crack we need an
expert to kiss home
mr. Walters I should apologize for
shooting my penis off it all sweat it
they gave me a vagina hey guess what I'm
Eric's [ __ ] no you're not you wanna sex
well that looks funny I'm a little
worried that it might be a little bit to
rehash II but overall it looks funny
Jonah Hill is so adorable